[Music]
hello and welcome to dear Hank and John
doors I prefer to think of it Dear John
and Hank it's the podcast where me and
my brother John talk about stuff and we
answer your questions and give you
dubious advice and it's fun we also
share all the news from Mars which is
have called bedrock distant from the Sun
and AFC Wimbledon which is the white-hot
center of America's most popular sport
and we usually start out this podcast
with a poem from my brother John
actually we usually talk about how we're
doing how are you Hank oh is that really
I don't know I don't know how the
podcast works I'm good you know what I
just did John do you know what I just
did like moments before this podcast
began did you get a new refrigerator no
better than that
is your refrigerator fixed that's what
that's what the world wants I ate pesto
that was taken out of my fixed
refrigerator congratulations on having
fixed your refrigerator and being able
to enjoy pesto in personal news today is
day 29 of my 30 day elimination diet
which means that tomorrow I can begin to
reintroduce food groups to find out what
I'm allergic to that's causing my
eosinophilic esophagitis at the very
least along the way I have learned that
many of the things that I thought were
required for a living
turned out not to be and that in fact
you can survive without dairy and wheat
and soy and essentially everything that
makes food taste good yeah I bet you
can't have pasta huh I have not been
able to have pasta in some time would
you like a poem for today it's kind of
on the topic now that I think about it
oh it's it's a pesto related poem it's a
poem related to consumer goods and pesto
would have been you know pesto all right
is essentially a consumer good it's
today's poem is actually a request tank
lluís oh my good longtime listener to
dear john and hank requested this poem
by not that long time
yeah a long time no he's listened to all
11 episodes you're requested
poem the world is too much with us by
William Wordsworth great British
Romantic poet William Wordsworth and
this is a great example of his poetry
the world is too much with us late and
soon getting and spending we lay waste
our powers little we see in nature that
is ours we have given our hearts away a
sordid boon the sea that bares her bosom
to the moon the winds that will be
howling at all hours and our up gathered
now like sleeping flowers for this for
everything we are out of tune it moves
us not great god I'd rather be a pagan
suckled in a Creed outworn so might I
standing on this pleasantly have
glimpses that would make me less forlorn
have sight of Proteus rising from the
sea or here old Triton blow his red horn
William Wordsworth expressing concern
about our relationship with nature and
our obsession with consumer goods way
back in like 1808 I guess I guess we
have less to concern ourselves with if
if it's been a concern so long then it
must not be a real concern right I don't
think that's how concerns work but I do
think that Wordsworth would be alarmed
by the proliferation of inside culture
but sadly I have to say that as much as
I enjoy a good William Wordsworth poem
in side culture is my favorite kind of
culture John I have a question for you
on the subject of poetry sure why do
poems yeah sound like poems we don't
talk like that in any other situation
except when poem ink you know what I
mean there's a way that you talk when
you're when you're reading a poem out
loud not you but a person all people
talk this way when when poems are being
read yeah sort of have to like like
emphasize the syllables more and make
the make the things sound the way that
they should it's like it's kind of like
performing a musical piece except that
there's a lot more room for
improvisation well I think you've well
there's lots of room for improvisation
with some music pieces but I think
you've hit upon precisely what it is
which is that poetry is rhythmic poetry
is
musical you know and so not all not all
poetry but lots of it is and so I try to
reflect when I'm reading you know what I
think the meter of the poem is and the
most common meter in English is iambic
right where it's to do to do to do to do
to do
that's iambic pentameter the world is
too much with us late and soon that's
the first line of that Wordsworth poem
and I don't know exactly why we use I am
back vent ammeter in English poetry
except that it sounds good
that did you did you did you did you do
something about it just fills our little
heads with delight in the same way that
you know I think I think certain kinds
of music do so that's my theory about it
but when I'm reading a poetry that isn't
in iambic pentameter like if I'm reading
you know a little bit of Walt Whitman
song of myself for instance I would go
in a totally different direction like
like let me let me give you the first
stanza of a song of myself okay I
celebrate myself and sing myself and
what I assume you shall assume for every
atom belonging to me as good belongs to
you so I feel like that's a very
different poetry reading voice than you
have when you're reading you know some
some of those Wordsworth no I disagree
it sounds the same to me it sounds it
sounds in the same way that it sounds
different from normal human speech it
sounds well I think it's supposed to be
at elevate you know it's supposed to be
elevated yeah yeah and it has like yeah
it has and I think the question is could
you read that in a way that doesn't
sound like reading a poem or is it the
poem itself that sounds like a problem I
mean I think a lot of I think a lot of
poetry you know don't does want to sound
like heightened language I think some
doesn't you know like Frank O'Hare is
having a coke with you you know that
poem right um no but but but I can feel
it all you're just trying to get me to
avoid reading you some Franco era and I
don't blame it or you know what about
what about some light verse like you
know Dorothy Parker you know like her
poems they still sound like
right right they still you know Dorothy
Parker poem still sound like poetry but
you know they're making fun of the way
that poetry sounds if that makes sense
so I think sometimes there's
self-conscious rights about it but what
if what if what if you just take song of
myself' and you just say it like words
like I celebrate myself and I sing
myself and what I assume you shall
assume for every atom belonging to me is
it guys good belongs to you
nope you still sound like you're reading
poetry to me I don't think there's any
way to avoid it because the language is
is precise and the language is chosen
and it has a rhythm to it right I mean
you could sort of like tap out good
poems and like I don't think that's a
bad thing I think that's a great thing
like you can tap out any great sentence
in in in in literature right like the
the first sentence of of Great Gatsby
and Mike Young is there maybe a better
reading of song of myself' of most poems
that isn't the way that we read them
because we sort of get caught up in the
way of reading poems that sounds like
poem no because I think you have to
acknowledge the heightened nosov the
language in this piece you do Bessa fish
like that I don't I think your
underlying concern is maybe that people
when they're reading poetry get too
obsessed with line breaks and I think
that's absolutely true like you should
try insofar as possible to read a poem I
think anyway as if you were reading like
you know as if you were reading aloud
but you know and the line breaks are
only there to give you like the briefest
of an I pause us rather than the pause
of like a comma or something but I don't
know I'm not an expert in poetry Hank I
am just a guy who read you a great
Wordsworth poem that you should have
enjoyed more than you did I did no
here's the thing that's happening I
think with dear Hank and John and my
being forced to listen to a poem every
week is that I'm starting to think more
about poetry and about what it is about
poetry that sort of rubs me the wrong
way
and now and and I there are lots of
poems that I enjoy like I you know more
modern stuff is always more enjoyable to
me I think because it's made for you
know like me and people who are alive
right now and so it requires a little
less to like there's a little bit lower
of a barrier to entry
like I like watts keys poetry for
example but III think that a lot like a
lot of it is the pretension and and the
way that we perform poetry sort of does
elevate it in a way where I'm just like
I can't like that it's like people
talking about how like about like the
the notes of raspberry and and twists of
lemon in a glass of wine when I'm like
you know what this tastes like
is freaking grapes it's grape flavored
alcohol let's get over it and I and I
yes I think that's I think you're maybe
not giving enough credit to like the
validity of other people's passions and
interests so as a counterexample I would
say that like a lot of people find the
language of science or the language of
mathematics to be very off-putting and
to be very alienating however that
language exists for the purpose of
specificity and for the purpose of
accuracy and so if someone's trying to
you know accurately map something from
inside of human experience or accurately
map a relationship between you know
contemporary human consciousness and the
natural world that you know you need
specific language to do that and so I
don't I just as I think that there's
nothing inherently wrong with someone
saying that certain wine tastes better
than others we're trying to find out
what it is about that wine that tastes
better than others I don't think there's
anything inherently wrong with this sort
of heightened language of poetry but I
will try next week to find a poem that
you will enjoy that is unpretentious and
is read in a way that does not sound
poetry deal I deal and I don't want you
to think that I'm criticizing you and I
don't want the poetry to think that I'm
criticizing it
I just just in the same way that when
I'm talking about science I like to do
it in a way that will be interesting to
the maximum number of people and and
lower those barriers to entry and and
make it yes alienating I think that
there's ways to do that with poetry and
that people who are in the otherwise I
think they're very accessible Wordsworth
poem instead
sorry about that
well upset let's do some questions John
does that sound good it sounds fine I
think increasingly that the way that I
wanted you to feel about AFC Wimbledon
is instead the way
that you're starting to feel about
poetry which is exactly unfortunate
because I just wanted to read a poem to
sort of like set the mood and now I have
to read a poem and then defend it every
week for 20 minutes our first question
comes from Zara or possibly Zahra who
writes Dear John and Hank can you find
some way to prove that my life is not a
big crazy experiment and that all the
people I interact with are nothing but
actors and everywhere around me is one
big artificial movie set and that the
real world is completely different to
the one I think I am living in now
period which is not really a question
because events with a period but I
appreciate the sentiment because for
many years I believed exactly that when
I was a child I believed that I was the
only real person and that Hank was an
alien and my parents were aliens and
that the entire world that I knew
existed only to sort of entertain and
distract me because I was the only real
human in this very complicated like
alien play about what would happen to a
human if you did various things to them
so I'm very simply do you think that
that comes from do you think that that
comes from a place of of like just
knowing a lot more about yourself and
and in like you know the experience of
the self is a much richer experience
than the experience of the other and so
it D is that where that like I think a
lot of people sort of like have this
thought at one point in their life right
yeah so there's a bit of a word for it
right Saul Saul Epps ISM the idea that
the self is you know my self is the only
thing or the only self that can be known
to exist and that I should act out of
that out of that belief like that's a
that's a you know big idea in Greek
philosophy and then moving moving
forward as well uh it's very difficult
to prove a negative or disprove a
negative it's very you know it's very
difficult to prove that that's not true
however I don't think that it is true
and I think like one of the central
facts of being a person who is alive in
a world with other people is that you
have to have faith that other people are
as real as you are
and that their experiences are as real
as yours that their grief is as real as
yours because otherwise
you will end up acting in a way that
puts you further from you know further
from connection to people so it is a
leap of faith to imagine that other
people are actually people and not some
kind of like complicated experiment but
it's a leap of faith that makes a lot of
sense it is the far more likely er
scenario for starters yes and I yes
certainly I'll also say that it would be
very very unusual for Hank and John
Green to have done a ten-year long video
pod project so that we could play this
one very small part in the life of Zahra
well I mean it would be unusual except
not from zoara's perspective because
from Czar's perspective essentially the
only thing that's ever verifiably
happened are things that happen to Zahra
right so there is no there is no world
outside of Zahra
to Zahra there and that's kind of the
challenge of being stuck inside this
prison of consciousness that like my
consciousness is the only one that I'll
ever have my eyes are the only eyes I'll
ever see out of I'll never know what
it's like to be someone else I'll never
be able to inhabit another person's mind
and like I don't want to minimize the
size of that challenge because I think
it's the greatest challenge that humans
face but I do think that the the
responding to that challenge by saying
like oh these these people probably
aren't real or I can't verify that
they're real so you know screw them I
think that's the wrong respects yeah so
the answer is uh can we prove it no but
it is the case everybody's just their
own person yeah as much as I can't prove
it I am still sure of it that said there
are a bunch of philosophers who have
ostensibly disproved solipsistic for it
but not not so many but yeah I don't I
think the right way to go about the
world is to assume that other people are
probably people who don't exist purely
for your amusement and or edification
all right we have another question this
one is from Christy who asks dear Hank
and John it's occurred to me that for
the last few years I've always been
between places I live in places
temporarily at university or my parents
house I travel between them as well as
around the country to see my friends
either due to a restless nature or
reading too much Carol
I want change and new things feeling
that I need to be moving what is home is
it a place is it an environment do you
reach a point in life when you find home
and how do you know when you found it oh
dang yeah that's a big question I don't
think everybody reaches a point in their
lives when they find home and I don't
think everyone needs to I have an artist
friend for instance who's in her 40s and
was born in Afghanistan and lived for
most of her childhood in Afghanistan but
but doesn't you know have a permanent
residence now and also doesn't
particularly want to have one she spends
a lot of time in the US and a lot of
time in Canada and some some of the time
in Afghanistan and she isn't seeking
permanence in the way that I would seek
it
but that said I remember that feeling of
restlessness and having read a little
bit too much Kerouac and it took me a
long time before I felt at home but now
that I do which is it's almost like
something that you see in retrospect
were you at least for me where I'm like
oh I guess this is home because I've
lived here a long time and I don't want
to move anymore and once I found it I've
been very reluctant to leave I yeah I
also feel very at home in the place
where I am but I also empathize with
Christi in that sometimes you know I do
love to experience new things and I do
love to do things I also love to sit and
stay at home and do the thing that I
normally do and have have a routine and
I think that what this boils down to is
the idea of I mean maybe not but I've
been thinking about this a lot the idea
of normal the idea of of the regular and
having and there's sort of you know
there's a push in my life and I think in
a lot of people's lives to avoid that to
be weird to try new things and
especially when you're young I think
that there's sort of a mutagenic force
of youth in culture and that's an
important part of that is is like this
desire to do things differently
but then when you settle into the normal
and you find a normal that really works
for you and it might not be society's
normal hopefully it is if of course it
isn't exactly society's normal and it
may be very different from society's
normal but the normal that works for you
and and of course that normal can change
from day to day and year to year it can
be a really wonderful thing as as kind
of think that it's underrated as you
know Hank I believe that stability in
general is underrated both political and
social stability
are underappreciated because we're
always fomenting revolution but yeah I
quite I quite like normal but there is a
wonderful like friction to you know life
before you settle into a normal where
lots of good and interesting things can
happen but I also found that time of my
life to be very stressful yes like there
was this constant deep down gnawing fear
of not having a safety net of not
knowing who my people were for lack of a
better term like you know not knowing
who I could count on day to day and you
know not not having a great
understanding some days if like you know
what my bed was even gonna look like
I've had the same bed for 12 years that
to me is the definition of home home is
that bed that I've had for 12 years that
like has you know Sarah shaped and John
shaped density yeah my definition of
home is is comfortable normalcy as as
much as my high school self and college
self would hate that that's gonna say
somewhere seventeen-year-old Hank is
spitting on 36 year old Hank yeah our
next question is from Megan who writes
Dear John and Hank I've been a
nerdfighter since 2007 thank you for
sticking with us Megan and I am
beginning my first job as a middle
school English teacher in two weeks I
moved from upstate New York to Southern
Maryland for the
opportunity and I'm very nervous that's
because you're not in the normal period
yet you're in that terrifying difficult
but exciting pre normal period
I want to cultivate a love for reading
and writing within my students while
also performing to the high standard
I've set for myself how can i balance
rigor with my joy in my job that's a
great question and in general Hank do we
have any advice for a new middle school
teacher the only thing that I would
really say megan is that you are doing
God's work
with God's people God's people of course
being middle school students and that I
am deeply and permanently in your debt
as is the entire United States of
America for the hard and good work that
you are about to start doing with middle
school students and especially a special
message to the middle school listeners
out there be nice to your teachers
they're trying hard and as you can see
right there they are maybe just as
scared as you are maybe not just as
scared but quite scared so I think
you'll be fine yeah I mean I just like
that you're asking difficult questions
like that like wanting to cultivate
cultivate appreciation while also
wanting to you know get good stuff out
of your out of your pupils that's what
that's exactly the balance that you have
to find and and I having never been a
middle school teacher cannot help you
with that but the fact that you are
asking it shows that you you know that
you care and that's probably the number
one thing yeah I mean my only other
piece of advice to Megan would be to
find good mentors people who are better
teaching mentors than John and Hank
green who know absolutely nothing about
teaching so I'm sure at your school
there will be good mentors for you and
you know I'm sure once you're there
it'll feel normal you probably are there
by now by the way since we're answering
your question belatedly and probably
everything is going fantastically but
yeah find good mentors that's always my
advice to anybody starting out any
career and and I also want to say like
people enjoy being mentors that's a lot
of times it feels like it's a one-sided
thing and you're like asking a great
deal of a person but if you find someone
who
you really respect and you like the way
that they do their work people will
often enjoy sharing that because because
if they're doing a good job it's because
they love it and they're passionate
about it and probably think a whole lot
about it and want opportunities to talk
about it today's episode of dear Hank
and John is brought to you by
enthusiastic mentors enthusiastic
mentors comm a website where you can
find a mentor who wants to be a mentor
not some person who feels like they got
tricked into it a real proper
enthusiastic mentor enthusiastic mentors
dot-com a website built in the future
probably tomorrow the day after by Hank
green today's episode of dear Hank and
John is brought to you by reading too
much Kerouac reading too much Kerouac
inspiring restlessness and change in
generations of students and humans
before they've realized that really
there's a lot of pleasantness about just
sitting around and watching Netflix with
people you love this episode of dear
Hank John is brought to you by poetry
written after 1980 poetry written after
1980 the only kind of poetry that Hank
thinks is for him today's episode of
dear Hank john is brought to you by the
truman show and the matrix which have
reinforced this idea of solipsistic that
these ideas are so new but they aren't
alright we've got another question this
question is from Blake who writes dear
Hank and John I'm a transgender man
which in my case means my parents had
one son and one daughter but now two
sons this also means that my brother now
has a brother my dad and brother not my
mom
have been very supportive of my
transition and refer to me as their son
and brother my question is how do I
brother son I feel like there is a set
of skills or a way of being that I don't
understand it isn't necessarily about
gender roles I'm not concerned with that
I won't be able to bond over similar
interests or anything but being a
brother and son still feels different
I am in my early 20s and my brother is
in his late teens what does being a
brother mean to you and is it in any way
defined by gender or sex how do I
operate as a brother and son both in
public and in private that's a big
question it sounds to me like you
already are a brother and a son Blake so
you're probably doing it right
merely merely by doing it yeah I I
always encourage people to like reach
out to other people in the trans
community and other people who have had
similar experiences who you can find via
social networks or or in real life in
meetings and but I think my experience
as a brother is that you know being a
being of brother or being a son means
you know trying to be a good person in a
relationship which is not that gender no
I don't think yeah I don't know though
I've never been a daughter or a sister I
but I would say that like there's a you
know probably as many ways to be
brothers and sons as there are brothers
and sons and and everybody does it
differently but the thing that they have
in common is is appreciation and love
and respect for the rest of their family
and and compassion you know like that
stuff and so if in a lot of ways I I
think that you have become a brother and
son just by being like just as everyone
else has you have you do the thing you
know and if your family knows that you
love you love them then you're doing the
thing right um do you love me heck yeah
come on alright we got a question from
Julie who writes Dear John and Hank I
was raised in a cult where we couldn't
read outside books I don't know what
outside books are I it's but that sounds
like the the vast majority of yes
correct I always love to read but was
only allowed a very limited amount of
material I left the church a couple of
years ago and I constantly hear people
talking about all the books they were
required to read in high school and I
wish I could have had a high school
reading list instead I was attempting to
teach home school to my younger siblings
which was a disaster my question is what
books would be good to read in order to
better fit into this new world I have
discovered outside
the confines of the one I was raised in
that is a fascinating question Julie
yeah the first short story I ever wrote
Hank was about a kid I was in hike the
first serious short story I wrote when I
was in high school was about a kid who'd
only been allowed to read the Bible and
had been homeschooled and all of the
language that he had was the language of
the King James Bible that's that was the
language that had been spoken to him and
then he found himself you know in in a
world where the King James Bible and
quotes from the King James Bible and
stories from the King James Bibles were
not the only quotes and stories and
language that were used and it was quite
overwhelming to him it wasn't a bad idea
for a story the execution was of course
just epically terrible but but yeah I
mean I think it's tremendously
challenging to try to live in a world
where the sort of common cultural
references are very different from the
common cultural references of your own
experience or of your own childhood yeah
at the same time like I wouldn't
necessarily be searching for the books
that that are gonna help you like
associate with other people and
understand their references I you might
just be looking for the books that
you're going to enjoy the most
what so what I would do is just pick a
bunch of classics of a bunch of genres
and and find find the things that you
might be into right yeah and when I say
classics I mean from from like today you
know The Fault in Our Stars being an
important I would say you know you
should read you want to start with a
book like The Fault in Our Stars that's
kind of a contemporary classic and then
but you want it you want to read more
broadly so you also want to include for
instance like a great boarding school
novel or a good sort of like comic
roadtrip novel like an abundance of
katherines really between the Bible and
the works of John Green you should be
pretty well set yeah yeah I mean I think
that you can't you can't try to read in
a systematic way to like catch up or to
be able to you know like converse at
cocktail parties
because everybody everybody's read
different stuff and that's good and you
it's good to be able to talk about books
that other people haven't read and and
maybe get them excited about them I
think it's good to have you know
different kinds of reading experiences I
will tell you the the five books that I
read in high school for school that
mattered the most to me and then Hank
will do the same thing number one for me
Song of Solomon by Toni Morrison
completely changed my life number two
Their Eyes Were Watching God by Zora
Neale Hurston number three
slaughterhouse-five by Kurt Vonnegut
number four The Catcher in the Rye by JD
Salinger and number five angels in
America by Tony Kushner those are my
five books that I read in high school
English classes that had the biggest
impact on me I feel bad about excluding
you know Whitman and the entire American
canon and Shakespeare and Wordsworth and
Theodore Dreiser and whoever else but
that's those those are the five that
really mattered to me that I read in
English class John do you want to know a
secret that I don't know if I've ever
told anybody yes I didn't read any books
in my high school English classes are
you serious no one I don't think I
finished any book Wow
really yeah what about like Romeo and
Juliet or something that's pretty pretty
short mmm that's not a book and no I
mean they printed in book form ah you
didn't well did you not have good high
school English texts like did you not
get I did have I I I had good high
school English teachers and I enjoyed I
enjoyed exercises in high school English
I I have very mild dyslexia and I read
very slowly and and when what would
happen is like I would be assigned you
know the three chapters for that night
I'd read the three chapters and then the
next night I have to read another one
and I just couldn't keep up and by the
time I was behind I was just behind in
reading the Cliff's Notes so I I didn't
and I didn't enjoy any of the books
because I was reading them to try and
churn through them as fast
possible I did not enjoy a book on right
I read Jurassic Park hmm well that's an
enjoyable book no question about it
I remember reading Jurassic Park in high
school and really enjoy yeah so I I
enjoyed Jurassic Park that was the first
book that I read all the way through and
like the first like adult book and I and
it and it did inspire me that didn't go
out and read longer books that took me
you know I probably in the beginning of
this process would spend a month or two
reading one book and like I couldn't go
faster than that so that's what I did
and in class it was like you like we're
reading these these like 10 books this
semester I just was never gonna be able
to do that what else did you read in
high school that was book length that
that you liked or that you finished can
you remember anything
I read the Mars trilogy by Kim Stanley
Robinson and and that that was huge for
me
and I honestly until college don't think
I I may not have read I must have read
some other books but I don't I don't
know man it took me a long time to
become a reader and now I read just like
you know I still read slowly but I read
a lot yeah you're a better reader than I
am now
well yeah you have you have every
everyone who has children will sometimes
look at me and like touch me softly on
the arm and say what's it like to just
read it is true that you don't have as
much time to read but I could choose to
read a lot more than I do because you
know at the end of the day after the
kids go to sleep I often watch
television instead of reading yeah so I
could definitely make better choices or
different choices on that I don't know
if it's actually better there's some
pretty good TV shows on these days but
that's really interesting that explains
oh oh a book that was huge for me in
that change that I read in high school
was th White's book about what what is
it what's it called the ones in future
king yes that one I never read it
actually but I bought a copy once and
cut a gigantic hole in it and put a ring
inside of it first there's a birthday oh
I remember you doing
and actually I remember looking at that
hole in that book and feeling like you
had burnt an American flag basically
yeah whatever you buy a book it belongs
to you you can do whatever you want with
it
that's really interesting also explains
your continuing fascination with Mars
that like it was these three Mars books
that had such a huge impact on your
reading life it almost makes me
sympathetic to your position that Mars
is of anything other than passing
interests well I may also point out that
I'm not the only person who is
fascinated with Mars and and in fact I
would like to see an analysis of movies
about outer space versus movies about
football the game played with the foot
not football the game played with the
hands and and see which there are more
movies about I bet there's more movies
about space well I'm sure that there are
more movies about outer space because
it's inherently far more dramatic
special-effects budgets are higher
people like to go to the theater to see
stuff blow up almost never do things
blow up in soccer matches only when
something goes very wrong with a flare
in the stands all right we got another
question and this one is from Erin who
asks dear Hank and John if you could add
any one mandatory course to the high
school curriculum in the United States
what subject would you focus on I love
this question great question Hank let's
answer together ready three two one
computer programming Mars I do feel like
not enough American high school students
are educated in the field of fourth tier
English soccer which is one of the
reasons that AFC Wimbledon doesn't have
as large of following here as I would
like but I think that Mars and AFC
Wimbledon should be off the list for
future courses
I really think computer programming I
think understanding how basic the basics
of how computers work and how we get
them to do stuff with and for us is
extremely important to contemporary life
so that would be my vote hey I like that
a lot I feel I feel strongly in in in
that regard as well I think that that
you know it is offered in a lot of
schools and
and I hope that lots of students are
taking computer programming even if
you're not gonna become a programmer
it's just a really important thing to
know I have taken computer programming
courses and I am NOT a programmer but it
is very helpful to me in my life to know
what is possible and to be able to
communicate with programmers so that's
great I you know just to go in a
different direction I feel like there
needs to be a course on how to live yeah
like how taxes work and personal finance
and and things like that I I would
really like for that to exist and then I
think that there should be a course on
critical thinking that is just called BS
detection 101 and I don't know I feel
like that's just something that isn't we
just you know it's a post like it seems
like it should be something that is in
all of the courses but somehow we've
lost it yeah I would I would say that
that I would say critical thinking needs
to be integrated into existing courses
rather than made into its own course but
I don't disagree with you about what
used to be called home economics or home
ekkuva to people's lives like knowing
how to you know like not overdraw your
checking account is very important and I
did not really know how to do it until I
was about 28 yeah alright and like and
that the consequences of it and like
just and understanding the difference
like what it really means when you have
a monthly bill and and like and what are
your like and and all of the different
ways that being that not having money
costs money and how to avoid them yeah
because I just I think that there is a
there's a huge there's a whole industry
in America that's based on people not
understanding how money works and it
just it's a great industry for making
poor people poor and rich people rich
and it makes me very very angry and I
don't know why it's not something that
is taught and and also I would like that
course to teach how to vote yeah how to
vote
not not which person to vote for but
just how to vote how to like how to
engage with the American political
system yeah and and and that no matter
how much money you have you has to have
the exact same number of votes as the
richest person in the world
our last question for today Hank it
comes from iam who writes Dear John and
Hank I just realized that iums name is
not iam because his user yeah is no I am
decadent I don't think that person's
name is iam decadent I think that
person's name is something that is not
in their email address okay anyway iam
writes Dear John and Hank do you like
cooking is there a go-to meal you have
when you want to be fancy what if you're
tired but don't want delivery thanks and
happy eating first off when I'm there is
no such thing as me being tired and not
wanting delivery yes even when I'm not
tired I want delivery yeah I do like now
that you do I want delivery right now
yeah actually come to think of it why
isn't there a pizza here oh right
because I can't eat wheat or soy or
dairy the go-to meal for me when I want
to be fairly fancy is a nice piece of
fish very simply grilled with
cauliflower some nice kind of you know
baked cauliflower and very lightly
boiled asparagus that's the perfect meal
for me but it takes a lot of work and I
just as soon have pizza delivery I think
for us it's either like curry like
massaman curry and he's sort of like the
fancy if we want to spend some time and
then if like I just want to eat and I
don't and I like honestly if I don't
want delivery it's because I don't want
to wait thirty minutes and so it's
something like like a tortilla with cold
cuts and cheese microwaved that's my god
that sounds terrible that's that's like
I need food
Foom hmm or just or just a cold cut
wrapped around a piece of cheese Oh God
or or two bananas oh yeah
- bananas sounds more reasonable to me I
have to say that I've had to plan my
meals very carefully over the last
thirty days because I can't eat any
normal foods and that's been really
helpful to me to know every morning what
I'm going to eat that day to know what
breakfast lunch and dinner are gonna
look like and to know when I'm gonna
prepare them because I don't find myself
in that situation where I'm super hungry
and you know have no idea what to eat
and then have to like ransack the pantry
in search of something to provide me
with calories because every morning I'm
like oh this morning I will have spinach
and then later today I will have chicken
and asparagus and then in the evening I
am going to have you know salmon
stir-fry or whatever god it's been a
long month hey can we move on to the
news from Mars and AFC Wimbledon let's
do that do you want to know the news do
you want it do you want it do you want
to know the news do you want to know the
AFC Wimbledon news okay tell me the AFC
you want the news do you want to know
you want to know you want it we want a
home game we did good
oh that's very nice we beat Exeter City
at home fans got to see a victory from
the John Green stand Hank thousands of
people sat in the John Green stand and
watched an actual AFC Wimbledon victory
beating Exeter City 2-1 and it was a
beautiful game the winning goal was
scored by our 21 year old striker Aziz
the new striker he was he was with the
team last season scored seven goals this
year an expanded role looking very
promising very exciting and and and Hank
currently five games into the season AFC
Wimbledon our 12th in league two they
are in 12th place
there are 24 teams in league to the
bottom to get relegated and then the the
top few get promoted up to Ligue 1 12th
is is dead center mid table very
comfortable not a bad place to be right
now
and hopefully if we can put a string of
results together we'll be up nearer
those promotion places and we can dream
of third-tier English football but it's
too soon for that it's it's just one
home victory but uh it was a good
weekend that is amazing news I'm so
happy for you and and also for everyone
because of how AFC Wimbledon is the most
important sports team and institution in
history I thought that you were just
gonna say sports team and I was gonna
have to correct you but I appreciate
your expansion Hank name another
significant institution owned equal
shares by every single one of its fans
you can't not even nerdfighteria is
owned by its fans no I actually looked
into doing that once it turns out to be
quite complicated I know but AFC
Wimbledon has overcome those regulatory
hurdles because they actually care about
their community unlike some people
what's doing Mars alright this week on
Mars well really on Earth a slab of ice
a hundred and thirty feet thick that is
persisted for tens of millions of years
was located on the surface of Mars it's
the size of like Texas and California
put together it's a very big thick slab
of ice that was probably deposited as
snowfall tens of millions of years ago
and it has it was very odd that it has
persisted for so long we don't
understand why and how it has happened
and it is you know we knew that there
was ice on the surface of Mars there's
ice all over the place but there were
mostly we were just thinking that there
were these big thick slabs at the poles
and that all of the water around the
rest of the planet would have evaporated
into the atmosphere but it looks like
that a lots has persisted all around the
planet
and it's sort of leading us to
understand that Mars has had a much more
variable and and and peculiar climatic
history than we expected and also it's
pretty cool that there is so much dang
water on this planet so there's a lot of
water on Mars right now yeah tons and la
Mars has had a more variable climate
than we
previously believed yeah were there
dinosaurs on Mars no but that would have
been high school Hank Green's ultimate
book it's Jurassic Park plus the Mars
trilogy oh you know what would be that
is if we were like you know it would be
it we could make dinosaurs but we've
seen the Jurassic Park movies so we're
not gonna put them on our no it would be
a bad idea to put them on earth but
we're gonna have Jurassic Mars Jurassic
Mars oh my god Hank we have a bonafide
hit on our hands
somebody called Steven Spielberg
Jurassic Mars we had Jurassic Park we
had Jurassic world the nut logical next
step
Jurassic solar-system Jurassic Mars
alright John you're the writer so I
expect to read a short story called
Jurassic Mars within the next six months
hmmm I'm pretty sure that that is a
copyrighted idea and they seem to
protect that copyright pretty
aggressively there's no there's nothing
copyrighted about the word Jurassic hmmm
I think there's something copyrighted
about the idea of bringing dinosaurs
back from the dead no well alright
that's that then it's settled we forget
writing a short story I'm a movie
producer now Hank I have a movie
producing deal with Fox 2000 I'm going
to make the movie Jurassic Mars do you
think Spielberg will mind no no
especially if it's really really
surrealist and and and crazy just stupid
- did you see Jurassic world
I know it's maybe it should be animated
and it should be for kids but there
should still be lots of blood and guts
Rasik Mars for kids I mean it's a great
idea for a TV show dinosaurs on Mars is
a fantastic idea for any format I cannot
think of a format where dinosaurs on
Mars wouldn't work see Hank when you
come up with when you tell me the news
from Mars I try to use that to make your
relationship with Mars even deeper and
better and
I tell you the news from AFC Wimbledon
you dismiss it and that is the
fundamental difference between us I did
mhm it's good to be supportive this time
thoughtful engaged sibling who is truly
a collaborator and you are an Underminer
you are trying to undermine my passion
and the world's greatest institution
owned by its supporters I did I did
everything I could
I'll try to be better in the future Oh
Hank what did we learn today other than
jurassic Mars what do you think that we
could get Kristen Bell to play Veronica
Mars the character and solve a mystery
involving dinosaurs on Mars you know
there's always one step too far
and you took it okay we need to keep
thinking like we've only had this we've
only had this dinosaur on Mars idea for
like five minutes okay let's not expect
it to completely cohere yet okay but
it's coming together all right I can
feel it I can feel the creative juices
working as soon as we go off the air of
the podcast I think you and I need to
set up some meetings with Hollywood
producers and that's just all dinosaurs
on Mars all the time all right
until then John what did we learn this
time well we learned that William
Wordsworth is a good poet whether Hank
likes him or not we've learned that we
don't know whether everyone else exists
but they probably do we learned that
being a good brother and a good son is
mostly a matter of loving and being
loved even though Hank wouldn't say that
he loves me thank you for spending some
time with us I'm Hank that other guy is
John he's my brother this podcast is
called dear Hank and John and you can
send us questions at dear Hank and John
calm this podcast is also something that
is edited by Nicholas Jenkins the theme
music is from gunnarolla and as they say
in our hometown don't forget to be
awesome
one other thing Hank you just said that
you could send us questions via dear
Hank and John calm which oh you can
you've created a website oh well it
doesn't actually did I well there's a
dear Hank and John Tom would calm it
looks Oh nope nope that's a different
thing
yep you can't submit questions via dear
Hank and John comm you have to go to
Hank and John at gmail.com confirm what
is this there's a dear Hank and John
calm yeah it's a tumblr where people
write us really nice letters it's really
yeah that's that existed before this
podcast did did yes we stole the idea we
saw the name from them different ideas
same name yes sorry about that dear
we're probably in retrospect maybe
should have called the podcast dear John
and I think Dear John and Hank comm is
available in fact I'm going to register
thanks for listening bye